RICH HYNDMAN: Hello.
I'm here to raise
awareness of the problem
of double-stacked phones in the
workplace, one for work data
and one for personal.
Now, some occurrences
simply can't be avoided.
But others can,
and they are just
instances of technology
getting in the way of life.
Now, I'm going to get into
something more comfortable.
That's better.
Always nice to be in
something tailor made.
At Google I/O last
year, we spoke
about enabling new features
for Android in the workplace.
We also included some
new profile management
and Launcher APIs in Lollipop.
It's all been
building up to this.
I'm Rich Hyndman,
and I'm going to run
through the features
of Android for Work
and what it means
for developers,
and how you can help
users avoid the curse
of the double-stacked phone.
Android for Work transforms
workplace mobility
with enhanced security,
consistent management,
and an open framework
for innovation.
It supports corporate-owned
devices and the use
of personal devices at work.
The latter's a bit more in-depth
for dev, so I'll focus on that.
In either situation, it
is important for a company
to be able to install Enterprise
apps for their employees
and ensure their corporate
data is totally secure.
But it's equally
important to remove access
to the information when
the employee leaves.
At the same time,
the user still wants
control over their device,
and Android for Work
solves it by allowing IT admins
to add a second user profile
owned by them onto the device.
They manage it with
device policies.
And we call that profile
the Work profile or Managed
profile.
For an improved user
experience, Android for Work
combines those two profiles
into a unified view
of both personal and work apps,
notifications, and recents.
The work-related items are all
bunched up with the Android
for Work logo for
instant recognition.
For developers, this opens up
some great new opportunities,
like benefiting
from bulk orders,
which easily enable installation
of your applications
across an entire enterprise.
So what does it take
for your application
to be compatible with
Android for Work?
Fortunately, not much.
There's just a couple of things
that you need to be aware of.
Firstly, as always
with device policies,
they may restrict use
of some device features,
like the camera.
So please always ensure you
follow the best practices
and code defensively.
Use the package manager to check
if a system feature exists.
And if it does, then
just catch exceptions
when trying to use it.
On a device with Managed
or Work profiles,
IT admins can also
restrict specific intents
from passing from one
profile to another.
In most cases, when an
intent is fired off,
it's handled in
the same profile.
If there's no handler for
the intent on that profile
and the IT admin has
blocked it, then the intent
is not going to be handled, and
the app may close unexpectedly.
The profile
administrator can choose
which intents are allowed
to cross from one profile
to the other.
And since the administrator
makes this decision,
there's no way for you to know
in advance which intents are
allowed and which aren't.
The administrator
sets this policy
and is free to change
it at any time.
The advice, same as before.
Code defensively.
Always check that
your intents can
resolve before firing them off.
Otherwise, let the user know.
The Managed profile
is sandboxed off.
This means it doesn't have
access to the files in the User
profile and vice versa.
It also means that you can
have the same app, your app,
installed in both profiles,
like Gmail, with totally
separate accounts and data.
Apps sometimes need to
provide other apps with access
to their files.
For example, an image
gallery will share images
with social media
or an image editor.
Now, there's two
ways you'd normally
share a file, with a file
URI or a content URI.
And, of course,
the file URI isn't
going to work if you're
sharing to a Managed profile,
as the file space isn't shared.
You should always
use content URIs
for sharing files between apps.
It's also a recommended
method for sharing files
anyway, as it gives you
control over the access
rights and period, and
you don't potentially
leak access to other files.
If your app is
sharing files, then
please check out our sharing
files training class.
Finally, the same applies
when requesting files
from an intent, like
taking a picture.
You specify content URI for the
camera to store the image in.
So please don't
double-stack your phones,
and don't make
others do it either.
Follow these hints and
make sure your apps are
ready for Android Work.
That's all for now.
Just some best practices.
But in the next Android
for Work DevByte,
we're going to cover launches,
app restrictions, and testing.
In the meantime, let's get busy.